[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
house a very spooky beginning although I
guess we do live in spooky times or as I
prefer to think of a Dear John and Hank
it's a comedy podcast not not anymore
guys
this podcast will never be funny again
it's no longer a comedy podcast our
mistake we should never we should never
create a dick comedy podcast in the
first place this is a drama podcast
about death
it's a dramedy in which john and i will
answer your questions give you devious
advice and bring you all the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon how you
doing John great how are you Hank I just
got oh I could hardly imagine a way in
which I could be better how about you oh
man I'll tell you what you know it's
nice is to look into the face of a
smiling child let's just think about
that Oh God
puppies are great man I have a I have
I've had a I've had a really pretty
intense stomach ache for going on two
weeks now more or less without pause I'm
not loving I you know what I'm finding
it hard to do Hank is like be
entertaining like I do the urge to be
entertaining is not really inside of me
right now so yeah this is this is what
you're gonna this is what you're gonna
get folks right well um like let's tell
me something that you like tofu pad thai
uh you know what I really like lately is
the music of snow the product if you
listen to the Hamilton mixtape no no H I
got it I got it like fess up here and
just like a hundred percent admit that
I've listened to like to Hamilton songs
that I've listened to a lot oh my god
you've got to listen to the Hamilton
mixtape Hank it's awesome
I haven't even I haven't even listened
to the whole Hamilton soundtrack John oh
come on
I know I know I'm a bad bad user of
popular culture I also haven't listened
to Neil says Regas new mouth moods
mashup album which I feel like I'm I'm
missing out on tremendously it is
terribly terribly important that you
listen as soon as possible to the
Hamilton mixtape because it will provide
you with hope in these dark and
difficult times and lots of people will
be like I don't understand what's so
dark and difficult about these times and
to those people I just say come on this
the scary thing is that like that the
the days between when we record this
podcast and when it comes out there's
gonna be so many other things yeah that
people might think we're referring to
sure but it's not those things it's just
it's the things from earlier in the week
it's the stuff from it's the stuff from
last week that what are you talking
about not even the new stuff but of
course by next week this stuff from this
week will have been forgotten because
the news cycle now lasts for four
milliseconds well that's the only way to
do it when I'm completely fit fascinated
by the new news cycle in which we live
where nothing is ever really news
because it is always supplanted by new
news but that means that the old news
never lasts long enough to be properly
contextualized so no one understands
what it means and then we move on to the
new news which we don't have time to
find out what it means because there is
now new new new news anyway here is a
poem by Carol Ann Duffy called the dark
it's a poem for children but I feel like
it's also a poem for all of us right now
if you think of the dark as a black Park
and the moon as a bounced ball then
there's nothing to be afraid of at all
except for aliens the dark by Carol Ann
Duffy
oh man on the list of things I'm afraid
of right now aliens are like like- i
provide i'm like aliens please come on
by tell us what we're doing wrong how we
do need some guidance help me aliens
that is what I would ask I would ask how
did you guys get through this period in
your history when
when it's concerned about the extent of
political polarization in the United
States and also the declining faith in
our fundamental political institutions
because those it's all made up ideas
Hank it's made up ideas that we have
agreed together to believe in and when
we start eroding faith in those
institutions by for instance arguing
that between five and seven percent of
all votes cast in the presidential
election were cast illegally by people
who don't exist or something without any
evidence of that like you just you just
start to erode that faith in the
institution itself in the idea of voting
being reliable and once you start to
undermine that institution you could
this boy when this happened in Rome it
was a big problem for them and not like
a problem for a few years but a problem
for like the last like seventeen hundred
years anyway John I think we should
probably do a question
it's from Christian who asks dear Hank
and John I was listening to your podcast
on my phone and I put the speaker on my
face when I felt the wind or some air
displacement acting as wind on my skin
is it the sound waves of the podcast
blowing wind on my face are your voices
touching my skin what is happening
thanks Christian yes yes what happens
are touching Christian skin I have a
question for Christian not to put this
back on to Christian but what why why
did you put a speaker up to your face
I don't know maybe because he wanted to
have our voices touch his skin so that's
really what's happening now our voices
are essentially caressing the skin of a
stranger well the skin of tens of
thousands of strangers and it's
happening to all of them all right now
simultaneous that's what sound is it's a
mechanical wave in air so air is getting
compressed and and like it's like
compressions and decompressions of air
that's what that's noise and if you are
really close to it you can totally feel
those compressions so it's not like wind
it's not air moving across it
is the it is changes in the density of
the air that you're feeling and that
when you feel that with your ears your
brain is able to interpret that as noise
and sound and words and then and then
decode those words into meaning and it's
amazing and isn't life beautiful isn't
humanity beautiful aren't we
something spectacular that his maybe
only happened once and shouldn't we just
celebrate that for a moment I got that I
got that this question comes from Ryan
Ryan identifies himself as not Ryan but
that's exactly the kind of thing that
Ryan would say so I'm gonna assume that
his real name's Ryan Ryan writes Dear
John and Hank when you die would you
like to be turned into a tree also what
kind of tree would you want to be once
you die I guess this is a thing it's
called the BIOS urn thanks for the pod
not Ryan
which is exactly what Ryan would say I
figured we could get back on topic Hank
by by turning the podcast back and death
to me which is on the subject of death I
know hey I'm not sure about this I'm not
a lawyer and and even if I were a lawyer
I don't think I'd specialize in wills
and trusts but I do believe that if you
make a statement about what you want to
happen to your remains on a podcast that
is legally binding so we're doing it
right now or we're last will and
testament John gets my my stereo and do
I get your stereo that way I can listen
to your music and you'll be whispering
at me from beyond the grave I'll be
caressing your skin with my dead dead
noises now it sounds beautiful sorry
what are we talking about what do you
want sorry what's got to be done with
your body are you gonna turn into a
birch tree ah I don't know I don't know
so John you have opinions about about
physical burial tell me about them it
will surprise you to know that I have
thought about this quite a lot yeah okay
so I have a friend who digs graves for a
living and and I do like I like the fact
that he'll still have a job like if we
I'll start stop burying ourselves what's
he gonna do I'm pretty sure that job is
gonna be taken by automation fairly soon
Hank no way I think there's a lot of
craft and skill that goes into digging
digging holes for graves because you
have to like you got to make sure you
don't kill the trees and yeah that's all
you can't automate that okay let's let's
get to the point here which is what do
we want to have done with our bodies
first off obviously I want to be an
organ donor I'm strong organ donor if
there's any way for me to be an organ
donor
yeah I want to be an organ donor and
then I don't actually care what happens
to my body whatever is convenient and
least traumatic for my family is fine
with me because I will be deceased so it
won't be of pressing relevance to me I
would however like a headstone and the
reason I would like a headstone is not
that I'm like a narcissist who wants to
be visited by people of the future it's
because I have found it very helpful in
my own life to visit the headstones of
my ancestors especially from our mom's
family the ancestors buried in Tennessee
but also our grandparents who are buried
here in Indianapolis I've just found it
helpful to have a headstone and a grave
to visit it doesn't actually matter to
me if the person's remains are
technically interred there I just I like
headstones I think they are an
underrated and underappreciated facet of
contemporary American life you know I
wanted to say that I think that it's
important when I don't have a strong
opinion about something to just not have
a strong opinion about it so I'm not
gonna have one I'm just not gonna have
an opinion about this but I do want to
say to Ryan and and maybe I should
because eventually something will have
to be done with my remains because I
will die but I do want to say to Ryan
that I would like to be turned into a
tree but I will tell you you can't know
that I am already being turned into a
tree the way wow you just blew my mind
that Adams work is there constantly
coming in and out of our bodies and I
breathe out carbon dioxide all the time
and so and that that car
but in that carbon dioxide was once part
of my body and and then that carbon
dioxide gets you know sucked into the
leaves of trees and turned into lignin
and cellulose and all of the proteins
and and structural compounds that make
up trees it happens all the time
I am already part of many many trees you
just go out there and you breathe on
some leaves you're part of that tree and
then you can go back and be like hey hey
friend who I just made and then went on
a hike with earlier last year I breathed
on this tree I'm in there I'm in it
that's me that's me tree Hank is it
possible that the only real purpose of
human life is to turn oxygen into carbon
dioxide god no no oh okay because I was
thinking what that would imply that
there was any purpose to human life John
let's move on to another question
god this podcasting IV this all of this
is gonna be in our next best of episode
boy yeah
Matty writes Dear John and Hank how do
we know that Mars wasn't the first place
humans were but we left it because it
was dangerous or something I assume the
or something is that the fundamental
political institutions for the nation of
Mars collapsed maybe there was a war or
it slowly became uninhabitable or at
first it was just like a lot of these
votes are illegitimate and then slowly
it became that the idea of certain
people voting was illegitimate and then
slowly it became that voting itself was
illegitimate engineers at NASA have said
that the evidence of water showed that
life could have been supported so how do
we know that that life wasn't us
maybe the reason NASA hasn't figured out
how to get back to Mars was because
that's how we got here and the
government has erased all proof and
technology please help me figure out my
true ancestry Maddy now Maddie
Hank is conflating several conspiracy
theories in this single question which I
love because that in in 2017 America the
conflation of multiple conspiracy
theories is actually the dominant form
of discourse to say it's great it's
really it's helpful for me it's a
glimpse into how how this stuff works
but I'm just going to answer the
question as far as
I know it and then you can answer the
question as far as you know it which is
that Maddie the good news is that we
know how long human beings have been
here on earth because of radiocarbon
dating or not carbon actually but what
radiometric dating I think it's called
but also for other reasons there's lots
of things in the fossil record that tell
us how old stuff is and we've had humans
for around 250,000 years we are very new
species and we did not come here from
Mars we know that we didn't come here
from Mars partly because early humans
did not seem to have any kind of space
going technology in many cases they
barely had Spears but also because we
know that 250,000 years ago Mars was not
a particularly habitable place so we're
pretty sure that humans are not from
Mars and even if they were I can't see
how the government one government could
have erased all proof I feel like it
would have had to be all the
government's and they would have had to
have a real they would had to be really
well organized and I don't know if
you've ever visited the UN but it's hard
for them to get much done i feet john
you answered that question perfectly and
wonderfully and i think it was great
there was nothing on a technical level
that i would add at all but i I would
add do we know Hank whether if life
existed on Mars like it's very unlikely
that there was like life on Mars with
two cells right yeah
well that's that's the thing about life
the vast majority of it even on earth
only has one cell I know believe me I
often think about the total weight of
bacteria being 1,000 times the total
weight of humans yeah they're they're
big and that's just the bacteria there's
all kinds of fun celled fungi and then
there's archaea there's just lots of
good stuff paramecium's yeah amoebas
brain-eating amoebas mmm yeah those
those guys they're really really quite
advanced they got a lot going for them
you know yeah
so the diversity of one-celled life is
remarkable but yeah the thing I want to
say though is maybe maybe but probably
not
cuz that's how far back sorry okay okay
okay
tell me give me your most realistic
humans came from Mars scenario try to
just try to approach it as best you can
be as realistic as you can humans came
from Mars all right when here's here's
here's the most realistic explanation
for how humans came from Mars we don't
know for sure that they didn't know
that's no good here okay listen I can
actually make a case that humans came
from our so this is no no no John John
this isn't how we make cases in our we
make cases by just by being very clear
that no one really knows any right and
it's hard to prove a negative that's all
you need and then X Y a so given that
you tap prove the negative conversation
it is probably true so given that you
cannot definitively prove that humans
didn't come from Mars even though you
can it probably means that humans did
come from Mars because failure to prove
a negative constitutes the truth of the
positive this question comes from Jill
you've asked the last three questions
all right you asked a question am I
never gonna ask a question ask a
question
I'd only want a little bit of justice in
this world John this question comes from
Jill who asks dear Hank and John how
nice do I need to be at the grocery
store well I'm standing in line at the
Express Checkout a lady got behind me
with only one item I let her go in front
of me seeing that I had about 12 things
in my cart right after that another lady
got behind me with only one item and I
didn't let her go in front of me and she
acted annoyed was I wrong not to let her
pass what if like four more people with
only one item each got behind me how am
I supposed to let how am I supposed to
let all of them through help I need
answers horses and goats Jill all right
Jill
a couple things first off you say you
have about 12 things in your cart if
you're in the express lane you need to
know exactly how many items you have in
your cart if it's 12 you're in the clear
if it's 30
you've committed one of the greatest
crimes known to man yeah well I mean
like yeah like like being nice at that
point is at is right out it doesn't
matter at all you've you've yeah oh
goodness
you've broken the deep down essential
rule yes
secondly and Hank I don't know if you're
gonna agree with me about this but
listen Jill last year the year before
that 1962 then maybe in those situations
it makes sense to let the person with
one item get in front of you but this is
2017 America and what you need to do is
take care of number one look out for
yourself and we all know from reading
The Fountainhead that if you look out
for yourself above all others and care
nothing for the interests or needs of
other people that the world will reach
its best possible stage I'm worried
about this podcast John why have we gone
off the rails no I'm gonna answer this I
think I think we're on the rails John
we're just on a different set I I want
to answer this question honestly for
Jill and I will say Jill you did the
right thing though I was being serious
you did the right thing in letting that
first person go and then saying okay
well there has to come a time at which I
actually check out but the person behind
you doesn't know necessarily that that
you've already let one person through
and so this is a situation that is just
clearly a small misunderstanding and in
the course of human history
I doubt will have a large effect on the
happiness of any of the people involved
it has shown that you have spent a fair
amount of time thinking about it which i
think is fine but you probably can can
now move forward out of this experience
and not not have to worry about it it's
it's the kind of situation where you're
like maybe you were short with someone
because you were frustrated with another
situation in your life and they have to
be understanding that sometimes the
reason if someone is impolite is not
because they are there are not aware of
the etiquette or they are not a good
person but sometimes they have bad days
and sometimes something is just not the
way that you know that it is it's
complicated and
I think the person who maybe thought
that you were rude needs to be a little
more understanding that sometimes the
world is more complicated than then it
appears at first to them to be one of
the hardest things about being a human
being is imagining the lives of
strangers generously and complexly and
nowhere on a day-to-day basis is that
more difficult for me than while
standing in line at the grocery store
like you just have to be able to think
it is possible that this person who is
being very inattentive in the way that
they're going about paying for their
groceries has just had an extremely
stressful day and that's why this is
taking 45 minutes in and if you can do
that it I don't know it makes it it
makes human life feel less like this
series of like minor oppressions in
which you're forced to participate in
bureaucracies and more like you're part
of a community and that is actually
quite a heartwarming thing and that you
know you you can be generous toward this
person you don't know and in doing so
like it will make their life a little
easier but weirdly it will also make
your life a little easier hey John do
you want another question now that I
fixed that static that was on the
podcast sorry everybody for that status
yes I do I do this one is from Zach who
asks dear Hank and John on a recent trip
to the planetarium I learned that not
only is the Curiosity rover much bigger
than I had originally thought but it
also has a laser for scientific in
quotation marks research given that
there may be life on Mars could this
giant laser firing robot be seen as a
hostile invader from the point of view
of microscopic Martian life were the
aliens in war were the aliens in War of
the Worlds actually just trying to do
research on us maybe they were maybe
they were just shooting their little
spectrometer laser and then vaporizing
us to see what we're made of does NASA
take that into consideration but yes
Zach kind of they do kind of Riyadh well
yeah I mean they they take the life into
consideration not so much the don't take
so much the
zapping it with lasers like I think if
if we burned up a couple bacteria on
Mars probably wouldn't be the end of the
end of the world but certainly not the
end of our world but it could well be
the end of the Martian world if those
are the last two bacteria it just seems
very unlikely that they would be out
there on the surface if there's bacteria
or if they're single-celled life or any
kind of life on Mars it would be very
likely below the surface where there is
less radiation to disrupt it but hey we
don't know but it's a big surface of
Mars and we're only in a very small
place but but I do like kind of like I
like the idea of an alien species just
like sending down this giant robot to
earth and being like what are you guys
made of I'm just throwing all of us yeah
like they don't have a concept of like
individual life-forms and they're like
well obviously you know this is just
like burning a couple skin cells off so
we're just gonna be like ah and burn a
couple of those human beings off the
face of the earth because they must be
part of a collective in which no
individual matters at all like like us
the aliens are and that could I yeah I
could see that I can see that kind of
like that that kind of ignorance because
it's so hard to imagine the way that
life would be for another kind of life
form because we know this one way that
it works like it's it's easy to forget
that all of the vertebrates on planet
Earth evolved from one kind of fish
that's why we all have two legs and two
arms and a head and a spine and like we
are already out like the exact same like
there aren't any animals with four arms
unless they don't have any legs and like
that any vertebrate many terrestrial
vertebrates and that like that's so
weird like even snakes snake-like
sometimes even have tiny little legs
still hiding in there and like manatees
have pelvises that float inside of their
body is not connected to the legs that
have now disappeared there's like tiny
useless pelvises that are just still
there that's a pretty good name for a
band
tiny useless pelvises better still there
that's a long name that's a long one
yeah maybe it's like tiny useless
pelvises our first album still there I
think I just needed to interrupt you
really quickly because earlier you said
that there are no animals with forearms
and that is inaccurate and I know that
Henry would be upset with me if I did
not point out that that is inaccurate
because of course there is an animal
with four arms it is called may champ
and good as a fighting-type pokémon yeah
also all the things from from Pandora
the world in Avatar
and which I always thought was like oh
yeah see differently laid out bodies
that makes a little bit of sense but it
didn't make sense to me that not
everything on Pandora had four arms I
was a little frustrated by that like
that there was some but not others I
could see it happening but it's unlikely
but it's why I like dragons for example
don't make sense because dragons have
wings and also arms and also legs and
that would be six total limbs and I've
just has never happened like you
couldn't it's like amazing that it's
never happened but it's like we have a
way of laying out bodies and and that
kind of radical change to the layout
just doesn't occur which is why for
example Weaver's are totally acceptable
which just have wings and legs and our
dragons but without the arms so go
weaver pnes from now on everybody that's
the what we're calling the mascot of
dear Hank and John the podcast the
wyverns I mean this podcast is so far
off the rails Hank that I I'm thrilled
that we now have a mascot but tragically
there's no one still listening it's just
you and me out here we're alone at the
end of that like we're walking on the
edge of the world looking down at a vast
abyss together and and we are like
laboring under the delusion that there
are people here with us but it's just
you and me man
I think I think there's a couple of
people who've held on just six or seven
that are hoping maybe we get to one of
the questions that they sent in and
they're like hey guys but like I know
that you got your thing and that you're
worried about your things but I had that
question that I really wanted to ask but
yeah sorry maybe it was this question
okay let's see this question comes from
Mary who writes hiya John and Hank I've
been wondering what the difference is
between calling someone blank the second
and calling them blank junior do people
call themselves the second two seem
fancier what gives
insert clever sign-off here m'kay Mooney
PS I was able to meet y'all in North
Carolina for the Tour de nerdfighting
when I was in sixth grade you two are
amazing and have helped me through so
much thanks a billion you're welcome a
billion Mary also it is very helpful to
know that you are from the American
South I have noticed that in the South
there are a lot of seconds and also a
lot of juniors but they are not the same
thing they are not and in fact it is
very important to me that you know this
because I am a second and I don't want
you to think that I'm just trying to be
fancy that's right
Hank's not just trying to be fancy no in
fact I actively attempt to not be fancy
despite the fact that I am I am so my
dad's name is not my name my
grandfather's name is my name and so I
am NOT Junior because I'll be Junior if
I had the same name as my dad but I do
have the same name as someone else in my
family so I am the second of that name
in the family that is why I am the
second right so but it is really weird
like why don't we have the second at all
and it's like an official part of my
name like on like on my driver's license
it's weird yeah that like like I'm a
king of something or like a pope I don't
need to be a second like like the second
of his name well I mean you are kind of
the Pope of our family I'm not kind of
the Pope of your family John I'm in no
way family obviously uh you know Sarah's
Sarah's the Pope of our nuclear family
I'm saying you're the Pope of our
extended family and what in what way am
I the Pope of our extended family I mean
if you told everybody in our extended
family you know
in Sarah Henry Alice Oran mom dad if you
told all of them like there can only be
one Pope who shall it be I think we
would I think we would blow the red
smoke for you
he said not totally confident on how
Pope Pope's get elected I you know I die
I don't know that you're wrong but I
don't want that I don't want that
responsibility well we have Russia's not
your fault but it's true oh my bad my
bad white smoke the white smoke I'll
tell you what I've always wanted to be
Catholic and I've always been as high an
Episcopalian as you can possibly be
without just going over and becoming
Catholic but but I don't I don't know my
Vatican I don't know my Vatican rituals
that well well John that will encourage
you to know then that this podcast is
brought to you by Vatican ritual Vatican
ritual you need it you need to know more
about it because even though you're
Episcopalian you have this weird
interest in Catholicism and that goes
for everyone
everybody is Episcopalian with we by the
way almost every Episcopalian I know as
a weird interest in Catholicism and of
course today's podcast is also brought
to you by the darkness the darkness
currently surrounding dear Hank and John
not just sponsoring us but also inside
of us the podcast is also brought to you
by facts we don't exist any more facts I
mean the weird thing is so like people
are gonna people are gonna say that we
have a liberal bias Hank but like you
know the truth about me which is that
it's very difficult to say that I have a
liberal bias because I am like not a
particularly politically liberal person
but I have been completely thrown over
the edge by the refusal to engage with
facts and data
it's just ideological rigidity scares me
more than almost anything and I am a
deeply afraid person and ideological
rigidity in the face of
Minh the face of like facts that argue
against your position just terrifies me
okay sorry lastly today's podcast is
brought to you by the grave the grave
one of the the great underrated American
traditions and also the place to which
we are all headed friends last night and
and one of my friends as a child who has
a blanket but he sucks on and the
blanket has just become disgusting and
and like I can't imagine that he lets
his child put this in his mouth and it's
like you have to throw this away but the
child is so attached to it that like
they're afraid of his like psychological
well-being if the blanket goes away and
I was like well you know like someday
his mom's gonna go away it's something
like we're all gonna die so yeah like
you start off you gonna be like that
blanket it's gone now it's gone it
doesn't exist anymore and someday that's
gonna happen to your dog and your daddy
and all your brothers and sisters and
now you understand death so that is that
was that would that be like the proper
way to parent John I mean I have to say
hearing that story I've never been so
proud of you know the response I
expected hey let's move on to the news
from Mars and AFC Wimbledon oh really
are we already there we've only been
recording for like 30 minutes I am in my
heart I just want to talk about sports
where everybody agrees to play on a
certain level playing field and
everybody agrees to play by the same
rules and you can't change the rules one
third of the way into the game Oh sports
Oh God well I have some really good Mars
news it's good it's very exciting Mars I
had some really good AFC wimbledon news
but I feel I feel like we should do one
more question maybe we'll do one more
question after the news get people to
hang on hang on sure that's going to
hang on through the through the the
darkness of the news that they don't
really care about that much I want to go
first John that's just not true Hank
people only listen to this podcast for
the news from AFC Wimbledon which is as
follows on January 21st AFC Wimbledon
played in Chesterfield it was a
thrilling nil-nil draw and life really
I mean not the best and then yesterday
as I'm recording this at least ASC level
didn't played Gillingham or possibly
Gillingham it's like jiff and gif nobody
knows how to pronounce it Hank and you
know what happened what happened I mean
imagine the most exciting thing that
could have happened is it a nil nil draw
it's literally even better than a nil
nil draw is it is it 3 2 1 one-nil down
to 2 on up that's the way they win the
Cup
Hank yeah the game was won not by AFC
Wimbledon or by Chillingham it was won
by our old friend inaudible pitch soggy
pitch yeah soggy pitch frozen pitch
that's the winner and AFC Wimbledon's
magic and Gillingham or possibly
Gillingham congratulations to frozen
pitch their first victory against AFC
Wimbledon this year but if history is a
guide not their last that's like some
really great news from Ames you able to
John so that in the first for the is
that are you done by the way that's it
man pitch emerged victorious well I have
to you that the first time a Mars news
is going to be brought to you by a press
release which which I it's very exciting
to me because I love this press release
and it is from the newsroom of the
Houston 2017 Super Bowl then and and
they would like to you to know that the
host committee unveils wow factor
experience do you want to know about
this wow factor experience John yes the
great thing about press releases is that
you could just say them exactly because
they are meant to be plagiarized so I
can just do this without having actually
writing down that's the whole point of a
press release the Houston Super Bowl
host committee today unveiled future
flight as its wow factor for the 2017
Super Bowl live fan festival featuring a
virtual reality experience and numerous
hands-on space exhibits future flight
will share with the public the
incredible journey to Mars and beyond
the unveiling took place at the 2016
space commerce conference and Expo
also known as space comm quote the host
committee has declared Super Bowl Li
whatever that is what is it 51 is a 51
li I think I'm not a Roman citizen as it
says the Super Bowl of the future in the
city of the future said Sally sergeant
president and CEO of the humid Super
Bowl host committee did I say human
Houston
nothing says future the human Superbowl
CEO of the human Super Bowl host
committee
nothing says future more than deep space
travel the human Committee is thrilled
to partner with NASA and I don't know
why they keep having to say that they're
made of humans but apparently that we
have to be specific now the human
committee is thrilled to partner with
NASA and the leading space industry
companies to create the future flight
experience for people to enjoy during
Superbowl live so this is actually a
pretty cool thing they're building like
one of those towers that like drops you
so but you're wearing virtual reality
goggles while it's happening future
flights key component is a virtual
reality ride that takes guests on an
excursion through space to the red
planet and back using actual footage
from Mars guests donned virtual reality
goggles for the two minute and 10
seconds right it concludes with a
90-foot drop they actually dropped the
people that transports the writer
visually from Mars back to earth landing
on the 50-yard line of the NRG Stadium
just in time for kickoff of Super Bowl
Li whatever Li is for guests who prefer
not to experience the 90-foot drop there
will be a special presentation area
outside of the attraction to experience
the virtual reality portion of future
flight without dropping off of a tower
it's very exciting John look at that you
could to go to Mars to sign up for that
one yeah yeah they got a special John
Green edition of the ride as well I
appreciate that for guests you don't
want to fall 90 feet out of the sky oh
god a badger that's the majority of
guests but you know these days people
will do all kinds of things for thrills
well that's great Hank I'm sorry that
you won't be at this this Super Bowl in
Houston I don't know for a fact that you
won't I'm just guessing based on
everything that I've learned
you in the last 37 years you're not
gonna be the super elf at the Super Bowl
in Houston but so that's gonna be a real
bummer for you to miss out at but the
good news is that you won't be at this
Super Bowl
yeah it seems unlikely shot seems
unlikely I uh
I mean I have to say I a Wyatt Wyatt
doesn't all Mars news come in the form
of breasts releases like that that was
fantastic
I was very excited I don't know yeah but
I I also fancy Wilden has good has good
press releases - for the record maybe
I'll start reading them on the pod do
childhood pink what did we learn today
other than the fact that like Hank and
John are not in a great head space right
now
we learned that dragons are impossible
but woman's are not it's true this true
I've you know I'm glad I'm glad I
learned that oh man
we of course learned that Hank or as I
shall now refer to him Pope William
Henry green the second is the Pope of
our extended family we learned that if
you breathe on a tree you become part of
that tree and can we just revel in the
beauty of life on earth for a moment and
how wonderful it is so deeply
interconnected and it is almost like if
you are a destructive force for it
anywhere you were a destructive force
for it everywhere I'm sorry I did I took
that to a negative place when I die man
you did you did you could it felt like
it's almost as if you are if you are a
destructive force against it that is it
is just such a harmless little caress of
breeze on the majesty that is the
constant and willful fight against
entropy that biological life is that was
actually quite beautiful and lastly we
learned that when you are standing in
line at the grocery store
you must endeavor to be kind to others
especially when it is difficult because
this will make your life better and also
everyone else's life better and isn't
that kind of what we all need right now
yeah just I just want to go to the
grocery store and like get twelve items
and go to the express lane and then just
everybody go in front of me for like
just like yeah and then at the end of
that process it's gonna I'm gonna have
12 bottles of wine and in my cart it's
gonna be my 12 items and then I'm just
gonna give the 12 bottles of wine to the
employees at the grocery store be like
hey you guys I don't know if you drink
but if not give this to a friend and if
you do have a nice night on me I totally
think you should do that but I also
think that it is absolutely criminal to
give away wine that you yourself could
drink Hank thanks for parting with me
but now please remember that we live in
a world where if you buy wine you must
drink it yourself and not share it with
your friends or with strangers unless
those friends or strangers can benefit
you in some way mmm
right of course well that is it that is
what friendship is for that is literally
the case that is literally the casing
that is the only reason friendship
exists is so that you can use that
friendship to further your standing in
life and then at the end you will still
be dead dear Hank and John is produced
by rosianna halse rojas and Sheridan
Gibson our editor is Nicholas Jenkins
Victoria bon giorno is our head of
community and communications our music
is by the great gunnarolla we will
endeavor to be less horrible next time
sorry but this is a real go it's really
going up over here in Greenland guys
Greenland is a nice phrase that we've
never used before
weird I don't know why I've never
brought that limit before you can email
us at Hank and John at gmail.com what
else is going on
yeah we're also on Twitter John is John
Green Hank is Hank Korean you can use
the hashtag to your hanka John if you
want to tell us that we got something
wrong which obviously doesn't actually
matter because facts don't exist and as
they say in our hometown please please
please please let's all work together
and don't forget to be awesome
you
[Music]